[Music]
how long was my streak of not losing
any classical chess game if you know the
answer send it to ulda
playmonus.com so you can join in our
christmas competition
good afternoon my name is uh sebastian i
love i have been summoned here by my
my boss and i've been hearing that you
guys have some problem against
magnus uh 9. i'm gonna take
him on today he is not to mess around
with
he is a tough cookie and i'm here to
show you how it's
done so let's go let's play against
magnus let's go
so not five years
i can't even figure out how it works
okay
i'm gonna be going for nine years
and uh there we go all right
messed around with we can actually
choose months as well i'm not
quite sure how many months so nine years
and
six months it is four months
nine years and four months and boom
let's go we have been given the black
pieces
hey i'll take it i take the challenge so
uh
c4 is on the board i'm going to be
playing knight f6
i'm going to be hoping that i can close
down the position because i know that
magnus 9 he doesn't understand these
pawn structures very well
nevermind he plays g3 that is a very
solid magnus
very solid all right so g d6 knight f3
we have the
good old king's indian line here so
uh there's a lot of ways this can uh
play out i'll play knight b27 and e5
rook b1 you know this is theory i
suppose he hasn't played d4 which is uh
quite significant we have a classic
english here fair enough magnus
so uh knight d2 he simply wants to play
knight e5 i guess i'm going to push my
h-pawn i'm going to go for h4 i'm going
to go for your attack
the attack is going to be dangerous i am
sure that magnus do not know how to
defend against the attack
i played h3 and he doesn't even take it
what's happening
i also for some reason thought that the
pawn was protected of course it's not my
knight is in the way but it didn't see
it so maybe it wasn't
so bad after all all right so queen a4
is on the table i'm going to be putting
all right maybe c6 c6 b5 though
then i have c5 oh
might as well close the position place
knight f3
i'll play knight take c4
just gonna take back with the knight d5
then
gonna strike in the center he doesn't
have his very strong white bishop
and that is not very very good
so i attack his knight and he refuses to
move it
okay magnus have it your way then i'll
take it
i'll take he takes back i'm gonna be
playing
bishop g4 rook tiwani attacks my queen
the queen is attacked i'll move her to
f6
rook t8 bishop h6 attack the rook
i'm gonna bug him some more here move my
knight to e6
potentially move it to d4 show some
mercy
hell no we will not show any mercy
we are brutal gonna take all these
pieces
and we're gonna win because that's what
chess is all about it's all about
winning
that's what it's all about and that's
what we are here that's what we came
here for
i did tell you guys that i was gonna
show you how to deal with
magnus magnus nine years old
so bishop bishop e2 he plays f4
can i take that with the bishop i think
it's gonna be mate
well he has queen g3 in the end then
queen g1 so i'll just take it with the e
pawn
choose the safe approach he plays g4
i'll start pushing my pawn
i'll take the knight and it's going to
be checkmate and one move
there we go so that's nine years and
four months
for you guys i'd say the strategy is to
keep the positions close and
we even increased our rating there so
amazing a very good game
very good game that's how you deal with
uh
magnus at nine and i will see you guys
[Music]
later
[Music]
you